جهاز مكافحه المخدرات في غزه يقوم بحملات
مداهمه بين فتره واخرى للحد من خطر انتشار
افه المخدرات رغم ضعف الامكانيات التي
تستوجب توفرها اجهزه فحص للكشف عن
المخدرات ومراقبه مستمره لكل الانفاق
وتجار المخدرات ومروجيها وغالبا ما يكون
حجم الكميات المهربه صغيرا مما يصعب من
مهمه اصطيادها
احنا للاسف الشديد على مدار 15 سنه من
الانقسام و15 سنه من الحصار الشديد
والحروب المتكرره بدات تظهر في المجتمع
الفلسطيني ظواهر لم يكن لم تكن سابقا
اطلاقا في تاريخ المجتمع الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه بدانا نشهد ارتفاع في وتيره
الجريمه بدانا نشهد ارتفاع في عدد
المتسولين بدانا نشهد بدانا نشهد شيء غريب
جدا انه بعض الناس تسكن في المقابر
من يضيق الخناق على الاخر ساكنوا القبور
ام الموتى ماساه انسانيه في قطاع يحاصره
الاحتلال من جهه وصراع الاخوه يزيد من
معاناه شعبه من جهه اخرى
على عاتق حكومه رام الله
حماس بالتساوي لان الحكومه رام الله هي
مسؤوله ايضا عن مواطني قطاع غزه كما هي
حكومه حماس في قطاع غزه فهي مسؤوله ايضا
عن توفير
متطلبات ابناء قطاع غزه وبالتالي لا يمكن
لنا باي حال من الاحوال ان نعفي حكومه رام
الله عن المسؤوليه عن كل الازمات التي
تحدث في قطاع غزه كما ايضا نحمل حماس
المسؤوليه عن عن الكثير من هذه الازمات
ما حدش دور عنا بالمره كتير نشدنا وكتير
جريت وكثير عملته على الفاضي مش قادر يعني
اكثر من هيك يعني ناس كتير يعني عندهم
عندهم حاجات كثيره طلع لهم وراحوا قدموا
بيطلع لهم بعد شهر وشهرين واحنا لليوم
اللي معناها من حرب 2014 بهدلنا في الحرب
وبعديها قال لنا سجلوا تعالوا وجريت ورحت
ما حدش طلع لنا قال لنا كل كل حكوا لي حين
يجي عليك حنيجي عليكم ما حدش اجانا ولا
احنا عشان الفقراء يعني ما حدش بتطلع لنا
احلام وفقراء غزه ومناشداته من اجل توفير
سكن لائق مازالت حبيسه جدران المقبره على
تجد صدى لدى المسؤولين عن القطاع من اجل
ايجاد حل جذري ينقذ اطفالهم من الضياع
ولكن لا حلول في الافق القريب
[موسيقى]